the only thing I'm pregnant with is a
lot of really good ideas yeah you're
pregnant a lot of good ideas yeah but
not any babies Dakota Johnson sets the
record straight about those pregnancy
rumors but a lot of people congratulated
me earlier this week a report claimed
the actress and her boyfriend Coldplay
frontman Chris Martin were expecting a
baby after Chris held a party at his
house complete with pink and blue
balloons and Dakota's famous parents
Melanie Griffith and Don Johnson well it
was my birthday yeah happy birthday but
the 28 year old stopped by The Ellen
Show and revealed the gathering was just
a birthday bash not a gender-reveal
party balloon that happened to be pink
and blue and so then I was pregnant yeah
because they assumed when the balloons
were released that it was a reveal like
a gender reveal yeah but but the I yeah
that's what happened yeah yeah yeah I
don't know what I I didn't know that the
balloons were gonna be released they
were just in like an arch but I guess
that accidentally happened one of the
ends just got let go yeah Chris and
Dakota have been together for about a
year and she recently played coy during
an interview with Tattler when asked
about her relationship with the singer
quote I'm not going to talk about it but
I am very happy
Dakota's birthday bash was just one week
after Chris's ex Quentin Paltrow tied
the knot with Brad Falchuk
in January Gweneth gushed to et about
her man I just am trying to move towards
into the scenes of it being scared of it
and I'm really lucky that I found
that's patient and loves me and is
willing to you know help me with my
process I like how you smile when you
talk about him you get this real twinkle
in your eyes when is it Chris have
remained friends since their infamous
conscious uncoupling something she told
et was a process you know it's really
kind of just an exercise in letting go
and forgiving and embracing what's
wonderful about the person and what you
fell in love with in the first place and
you know there it is possible to sort of
separate out the romantic part and still
forge that wonderful familial
relationship with somebody
[Music]